la fin des vacances a sonné aurélia huit
ans rentre en ce2 à l'école élémentaire
vigée-lebrun de bois d'arcy son père
accompagne sa petite dernière pour sa
reprise
j'ai pris quelques heures pour
vous les ramenez pour amener ma fille à
l'école un retour à l'école amorcée
pendant les vacances on va pas il m'a
fait recours à la maison m comme aurélia
252 élèves font leur rentrée à l'école
élémentaire vigée-lebrun de bois d'arcy
pour certains parents c'est une journée
marquante avec l'entrée au cp de leurs
enfants
on a pris un toujours la première
journée si ça va bien se passer
c'est alors à ses repères bon voilà
c'est un peu stressant
les élèves eux sont inquiets de la
composition de leur classe tous
regardent la liste avec attention s'il
est content d'être avec tous ses
camarades tant mieux quoi c'est parti
pour une bonne rentrée dernier bisou aux
parents la première journée d'école de
l'année débute en musique on a choisi
des deschamps relativement facile avec
des refrains qui sont faciles à
mémoriser donc les élèves nouveaux vont
pouvoir s'intégrer tout de suite au
groupe de l'école une reprise également
pour les enseignants de cette école
élémentaire c'est la quatorzième rentrée
pour cette maîtresse il faut voilà les
mettre en confiance ils m'ont la plupart
me connaissent déjà mais voit s'assurer
de ça et on va suivre bien sûr instauré
les principales règles de vie pour qui
se défend bien pour les religions
prochaines vacances le 16 octobre au
soir avec avant la traditionnelle photo
de classe